hello everyone and welcome back to game
review my name is Caleb den me and today
I'm gonna be taking you through a game
between Mikhail Botvinnik and Mikhail
Tao totally mispronounced their first
names but what are you gonna do it's
tough I don't speak Russian
efore c6 d4 d5 is how this game began
of course entering the caro-kann in the
game white chose the advanced variation
with E 5 and this is one of the most
testing variations but caro-kann
actually this one puts a lot of pressure
on black and as we'll see in this game
it's one fitting of towel style it
involves some some crazy pawn pushes
some crazy some crazy attacking styles
with you know White's kind of forgoing
all sense of positional play going
straight for the throat with an attack
on the Kings side in the game black
chose Bishop f5 this is the main line of
the advanced variation these days
sometimes black goes for this early c5
move but Bishop f5 the old main line
still totally playable today white plays
this move h4 and these days I like this
move h5 from black here and it keeps an
eye on this g4 square but in this game
Botvinnik played h6 this is kind of an
older way of playing and now towel
expands right away with GE 4 black
brings this Bishop back actually to d7
rather than stepping back along this
file losing control of the e6 square
Bishop d7 keeps things a little bit more
solid white now expands further with h5
and black goes ahead and challenges the
center immediately with c5 and this is
kind of the the feeling you should get
if you're playing the Cairo and this
type of position here when white starts
going crazy on the Kings side with all
of these pawn pushes the best thing for
you to do as normal is to counter in the
center it's the old saying you want to
counter and attack on the flank and
attack on the wing with an attack in the
center you want to challenge the center
of the board and that's what bots
Finnick does here we see c3 supporting
this d4 pawn black follows up with
knight c6 this Bishop comes out to
h3 once again trying to I'd this e six
square very dangerous and so black place
six himself not allowing light to break
through with this dangerous move white
continues development with not ninety
two but instead Bishop III and now black
plays this annoying move Queen b6 and
quit b6 is probably the reason this
Bishop III move isn't so good it creates
some very annoying threats to this b2
pond and if if white isn't careful black
is simply going to take this pawn you
can play something like ninety two but
now Queen takes b2 will come through and
this is going to be a comfortable extra
pawn for black here white isn't really
in time to break through with moves like
rook b1 so in the game
white defended the pawn with Queen b3
but now the problem is for white with
the Queen's coming off the board he's
created a lot of weaknesses both on the
Kings side and in the center and that's
what really made the difference in this
game we saw C takes d4 Queen takes b6 it
takes b6
C takes d4 and now Knight a5 already
black is threatening to bring this
Knight to the annoying c4 square white
simply develops with Knight c3 and now
we see b5 from black pushing this pawn
up the board making its presence known
bishop f1 was White's choice threatening
to take this pawn and after b4 might
actually brings this night all the way
up to the b v square and at first glance
you might start panicking if you're the
black player here because 97 is a pretty
serious threat and you need to do
something about it but with the Queen's
off the board and with the center so
closed King d8 is actually a perfectly
fine response for black here it keeps an
eye on the c7 square it steps out a 96
check and it gives black a perfectly
fine position and the King is going to
be relatively safe on this d8 square
Knight f3 is White's choice now after
Knight c4 it's Knights a little bit
lonely out on the be 5 square it's a
little defender here totally cut off by
this knight on c4 after Bishop takes c4
we see D takes c4 and
has the same problem it must step to the
d6 square where it can be captured and
now this pawn is not long for this world
it's a bit too difficult to keep
developed black chose this bishop c6
move creating an annoying pin on this
diagonal white tried to break out of it
tactically in classic tile style with
Knight e5 but simply Bishop takes h1 is
enough for black white does take this f7
pawn and take this h8 rook well sorry
after Knight check black played King e8
rather than King g7 we seen Knight takes
h8 but now Bishop efore is a very nice
move by black keeps this Knight under
pressure on this HH squared not so easy
to break free just yet white chose this
interesting move d5 trying to get this
bishop to some better squares but I can
simply capture this pawn bishop d4
doesn't really come with a devastating
effect that towel was probably hoping
for blacks tip black simply develops and
cuts off this bishop from the attack on
the g7 pawn king d2 is White's choice
getting the rook giving the rook the
ability to move two more squares on this
first rank but now King d7 by Botvinnik
and he's easily collecting this D pawn
after 95c King takes d6 and in this
endgame let's do a quick count of the
pawns 1 2 3 4 5 6 - 1 2 3 3 4 5 black is
simply up upon here and in addition to
that these pawns are pretty far advanced
they are definite key players in the
position they control a lot of squares
and put a lot of pressure on black on
white rather white chose f3 to try and
help his position we see Bishop h7 and
now G 5 another interesting try it by
towel he always comes up with these nice
pawn sacrifices to give himself chances
but once again Botvinnik simply captures
it and it's not enough here age six was
towels idea and after G takes age 6 we
see Knight f7 regaining at least one of
these pawns but
after Knight takes h6 Knight g8 is
actually how Botvinnik chooses to evict
this knight Knight g4 Bishop f5 this
Knight comes back to e3 but simply
Bishop g6 the players repeated once and
actually twice but now after Knight g4
Botvinnik of course isn't going for the
repetition here he's up to clean pawns
in this position simply king d6 Knight
e5 was tells choice but this game is
pretty much over here tau regains this
g5 pawn but it's not enough simply 97
and after f4 knight c6 Knight f3 in this
position white has regained one of the
ponds but black has solved all of his
problems black has developed this Knight
back to the c6 square where it controls
the board this bishops well placed to
blockade this pawn on f4 and this rook
push puts nice pressure on the a to pawn
and the fact is none of the white pieces
can really move here so after king d6
tile threw in the towel and resigned
this game play might have continued with
something like Bishop g7 but now simply
even king c5 and these pawns are gonna
roll down the board quite quickly so a
very nice game by Botvinnik shows the
power of the caro-kann shows why white
should not go up against the caro-kann
unless he's ready to lose in a horrible
horrible endgame in a horrible fashion
let this be a word of warning to you
caro-kann players be careful don't let
black trade Queens because if you do
you're gonna be in for a pretty painful
loss thank you very much for joining me
this week on my name is Caleb Dunn be
and I will see you in the next episode